Tüliye Iner, ich bin als Assistenzärstin auf der Session Tetic. Heute werde ich mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschäft durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne.
Zuerst werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihren persönlichen Daten stellen. Danach kommen wir zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden und Ihrer Krankengeschichte.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder Fragen haben, sagen Sie mir bitte Bescheid.
Danke.
Also, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Ralf Fischer.
Ralf Fischer?
Könnten Sie bitte Vor- und Nachnamen langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Mein Vorname ist Ralf, Richard, Alpha, Ludwig, Friedrich. Mein Vorname ist Fischer, Friedrich, Ida, Siegfried, Caesar, Heinrich, Emil, Richard.
Herr Fischer, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 73 Jahre alt.
73 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 3.3.1953.
53. Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege 85 Kilogramm.
85 Kilogramm. Wie gross sind Sie?
1,65 Meter.
1,65 Meter?
Jawohl.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Rentner.
Rentner. Was haben Sie früher gemacht?
Ich war Busfahrer.
Busfahrer?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe Kinder, ja. Ich habe einen Sohn.
Einen Sohn. Ja, schön.
Nicht Kinder, sondern nur ein Kind. Ein Sohn.
Ich habe nicht...
Ich wollte das nur korrigieren. Ich habe gesagt, ich habe Kinder, aber ich habe ein Kind. Hab ich noch gesagt.
Ein Kind, ja.
Ein Sohn.
Okay. Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Das ist Dr. Walter.
Walter.
In Frankfurt.
In Frankfurt, ja. Schön. Ich wohne in Frankfurt.
Herr Fischer, was kann ich für Sie tun? Welche Beschwerden haben Sie?
Folgendes. Ich habe seit sechs Monaten ab und zu Schmerzen im Bereich meiner rechten Leiste.
Seit drei Wochen haben die Schmerzen in meiner Hüftregeln, in meiner Leiste vorne, zugenommen.
Sie haben seit sechs Monaten immer wiederkehrende Schmerzen im Bereich der rechten Leiste.
Rechten Leiste.
Und seit drei Wochen habe ich stetige Schmerzen in meiner rechten Leiste. Ich kann nicht mehr richtig laufen.
Mein Problem ist, wenn ich Treppen laufen möchte oder wenn ich lange Strecke laufe, geht nicht.
Wenn ich morgens aufstehe, muss ich erst mal zehn Meter laufen, dass ich ein bisschen besser laufen kann.
Ich habe verstanden. Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Stechend, dumpf, drückend.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das beschreiben soll. Das zieht mir bis ins Knie, der Schmerz.
In mein Oberschenkel. Das zieht mir so rein, wenn ich laufe.
Oberschenkel.
Oder bis ins Knie.
Bis ins Knie hinein.
Ich würde sagen, ich bin bei sieben.
Also wenn ich mich bewege. Wenn ich mich bewege, bei zwei.
Waren Sie schon einmal deswegen beim Arzt?
Nein, ich bin jetzt das erste Mal zu Ihnen gekommen.
Okay. Nehmen Sie dagegen Schmerzmittel?
Ja, ich habe zu Hause Ibuprofen 400 Milligramm und die nehme ich bei Bedarf ein.
Manchmal zwei Tabletten am Tag, manchmal drei.
Mit den Schmerzmitteln kann ich meine Schmerzen ein bisschen lindern.
Ich möchte kurz zusammenfassen. Sie haben ca. sechs Monate,
und in den letzten drei Wochen sind sie rechtseitig.
Diese Schmerzen wurden in den letzten drei Wochen besonders schmerzhaft.
Diese Schmerzen strahlen in den Oberschenkel und ein bisschen in den Knie aus.
Die Schmerzintensität ist bei Bewegung, bei Belastung, bei sieben von Sin, Inruhe, zwei von Sin auf der Schmerzskala.
Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Ja, genau. Aber am Anfang haben Sie, ich habe seit sechs Monaten nicht Dauerschmerzen, sondern immer wiederkehrende Schmerzen.
Immer wiederkehrende Schmerzen.
Ja, ich habe immer wiederkehrende Schmerzen.
Mal Schmerzen, mal nicht Schmerzen. Und die Schmerzen waren auch nicht so stark.
Sie nehmen bei Bedarf Ibuprofen.
Haben Sie andere Beschwerden? Zum Beispiel Rücken- oder Knie- oder Fußschmerzen?
Knie manchmal ist beim Laufen halt, weil der Schmerz ein bisschen ausstrahlt. Aber ansonsten habe ich keine weiteren Rückenschmerzen. Sonst fühle ich mich gut.
Jetzt werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Allgemeinen Zustand stellen. Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich habe keine Fieber.
Haben Sie Atemnot, Husten, Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Apathit?
Der ist gut.
Gut, ok. Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, ich würde sagen, ich schlafe gut.
Meine Frau sagt, ich würde beim Schlafen Sie stören, weil ich sehr viel Schnarche und Schlafaussetze habe. Aber ich selber schlafe gut.
Ja, ich freue mich. Ok. Ist Ihnen schwindelig oder übel?
Nein.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ap- oder Zugenomen?
Nichts Besonderes, nein.
Ok. Haben Sie nachts Schweiß, kaltes Schweiß bemerkt?
Nachtschweiß? Was meinen Sie mit Nachtschweiß? Dass ich schwitze? Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Ja, ich schwitze in der Nacht.
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt. Nein.
Herr Fischer, haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen? Zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck?
Ja, Bluthochdruck nehme ich gegen Medikamente ein.
Seit wann leiden Sie an Bluthochdruck?
Ich würde sagen, seit ca. 20 Jahren.
Haben Sie andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, andere. Nein, nicht dass ich sie nicht möchte.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie gegen Bluthochdruck ein?
Ich nehme Ramiplil, 10 mg ein. Morgens und abends eine Tablette.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als ich 15 Jahre alt war, wurde ich an Blinden operiert.
War diese Operation komplikationlos?
Ja, das war komplikationlos. Es war alles gut gelaufen.
Haben Sie andere Operationen?
Nein, keine.
Herr Fischer, nehmen Sie Ramiplil und Ibuprofen andere Medikamente ein?
Nein.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche.
Wie viele Zigaretten rauchen Sie täglich?
Früher war es viel, aber jetzt rauche ich so fünf Zigaretten am Tag.
Seit wann haben Sie fünf Zigaretten?
Ja, ich würde sagen, seit ich fünf Zigaretten habe.
Seit 13 Jahren?
Seit 10 Jahren habe ich fünf Zigaretten.
Aber davor habe ich immer eine Packung geraucht.
Als ich 60 war, habe ich mir gesagt, ich muss meinen Rauchen ein bisschen einschränken.
Ich werde ein bisschen älter.
Wie viele Zigaretten haben Sie vorher geraucht?
Vorher, seit meinem 20. Lebensjahr hatte ich immer eine Packung geraucht.
Mit 20, 16 Jahren?
Das heißt, von 20 bis 60 Jahren habe ich 40 Jahre lang eine Packung Zigaretten am Tag gemacht.
Das ist ein Jahr.
Wie Sie wissen, das ist sehr viel.
Wenn Sie aufhören wollen, kann ich Ihnen ein Flaier geben.
Ein was geben habe ich nicht verstanden?
Flaier.
Ah, ein Flaier. Oh, danke.
Okay. Herr Fischer, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ab und zu mal ein Glas Wein. Abends oder eins bis zwei Glas. Nach dem Essen gönne ich mir einen.
Ein oder zwei Glas Wein jeden Abend?
Ja, fast jeden Abend. Also nicht jeden Abend.
Seit wann?
Seit längerem. Ich genieße gerne, wenn ich abends esse, immer ein Glas Wein.
Wenn es dazu passt, manchmal passt das Essen nicht dazu, dann trinke ich es auch nicht.
Man kann sagen, durchschnittlich ein Glas Wein trinke ich.
Seit wann weiß ich nicht.
Oh Gott, da weiß ich nicht.
40 ist das Lebensjahr. Ungefähr. Also 40, 45, 43 Jahre kann man sagen.
Okay. Das ist eine Routinefrage. Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Drogen? Ich und Drogen? Ah, ja, ja, ja. Nee, sowas nehme ich nicht ein.
Nein, nein. Okay. Gibt es in der Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Chronische Erkrankungen? Ich weiß nicht, was Sie mit chronischen Erkrankungen meinen.
Zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit, Füße, Unterfunktion.
Mein Sohn hat Bluthochdruck. Ihr Vater oder Ihre Mutter?
Mein Vater hat Bluthochdruck. Das stimmt. Und mein Sohn hat Bluthochdruck.
Okay. Wie alt ist er?
Der Sohn nimmt eine halbe Tablette wenig ein, aber der ist 38 Jahre alt.
Der wird 39 dieses Jahr. 38. Der ist 38. 38. Ja.
Bei dem hat es ein bisschen früher angefangen.
Und Ihre Mutter?
Die ist ein bisschen übergewichtig.
Also, sie war übergewichtig. Meine Eltern leben nicht mehr.
Und meine Mutter hatte auch eine Zuckererkrankung.
Okay. Sie sind verheiratet. Sie wohnen mit Ihrer Frau.
Ja, ich lebe mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Sind Sie gegen etwas allergisch?
Allergisch würde ich nicht sagen. Aber Vertragen tue ich nicht.
Wenn ich ab und zu mal dieglofenak nehme, kriege ich Bauchschmerzen.
Dieglofenak. Unvergleichlichkeiten.
Da kriege ich Bauchschmerzen, ja. Aber Allergien sind nicht bekannt.
Vertragen Sie alle Lebensmittel gut?
Noch einmal bitte. Vertragen.
Ja.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Gegen Covid-19?
Covid-19 damals, ja auch. Ich achte auf meine Impfungen.
Okay. Und?
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Herr Fischer, ich möchte eine zusätzliche Frage stellen.
Haben Sie ein Unfall oder Gechütz vor sechs Monaten?
Ja, keine. Kein Unfall. Ich bin nicht gestürzt, nein.
Okay. Ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Haben Sie an mich Fragen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, wie geht es denn weiter, Frau Doktor? Was habe ich denn?
Was wird jetzt alles mit mir passieren? Was wird gemacht?
Zuerst werde ich Ihnen körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Danach werde ich bei Ihnen Blutabnahmen.
Und wir würden Röntgenbild, Hüftgelenk-Röntgenbild und gegen Ebenenfalls MRT oder CT durchführen.
Okay.
Wenn ich alle Ergebnisse bekommen habe, werde ich Ihnen alles erklären.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen und für das Aufnahmegespräch.
Okay, danke.
Herr Fischer, dann würde ich auch gerne eine Frage stellen.
Wie bitte?
Ich würde fragen, Herr Fischer.
Bitte schön.
Ist Ihnen eine Schwellung in der rechten Leiste aufgefallen?
Und die zweite Frage, wenn Sie husten und niesen, haben Sie mehr Schmerzen oder nicht?
Nein, also eine Schwellung in meiner rechten Leiste ist nicht aufgefallen.
Und wenn ich huste oder niese, habe ich nicht unbedingt mehr Schmerzen.
Darf ich bleiben?
Danke schön.
Sagen Sie mir bitte, wie sieht das betroffene Bein aus?
Ich meine Blase aus?
Wie sieht das aus?
Ja, da.
Beide Beine haben dieselbe Farbe, das ist nicht auffällig.
Es ist auch nicht warm oder kalt.
Fühlen Sie keine Haarausfall?
Kein Haarausfall?
Nein, Haarausfall ist auch nicht vorhanden.
Okay, danke.
Darf ich eine Frage?
Haben Sie ein krippes Gefühl?
Ein krippes Gefühl?
Ein krippes Gefühl habe ich auch nicht, nein.
Darf ich?
Haben Sie Belehrungen, Übelkeit oder Emesis?
Emesis?
Nein, müssten Sie erbrechen.
Erbrechen, nein, ich habe kein Erbrechensgefühl oder Bauchschmerzen.
Nein, habe ich kein Problem damit.
Okay.
Eins wurde nicht gefragt, kann ich dazu etwas ergänzen?
Ob ich eine Lebungserscheidung habe in meinen Beinen?
Habe ich auch nicht.
Kraftlosigkeit meinen Sie vielleicht?
Kraftlosigkeit, genau.
Oder Lebung, Kraftlosigkeit, genau.
In meinen Beinen habe ich auch nicht.
Gibt es Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Könnten Sie etwas erinnern?
Ja, also warum ich diese Schmerzen habe, das kann ich nicht.
Auslöser für den Schmerz, dass er schlimmer wird, ist, dass ich laufe.
Meine Belastung.
Ansonsten warum ich das seit sechs Monaten habe, ich weiß nicht.
Ich bin nicht gestürzt.
Ich hatte keine besondere Erkrankung oder ich kann mich nicht erinnern, warum das gekommen ist.
Das ist einfach gekommen.
Das war am Anfang wenig und dann ab und zu mal immer wieder.
Und seit drei Wochen hört das nicht mehr auf.
Hinken Sie, hinken Sie.
Ja, also ich laufe nicht ganz normal, das stimmt.
Okay, gibt es andere Fragen?
Von meiner Seite aus nicht.
Hoffentlich kriegt Ihr mich gesund.
Machen Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Früher, als ich jung war, habe ich Fußball gespielt gehabt.
Aber später bin ich öfters Fahrrad gefahren und in letzter Zeit nicht mehr so viel.
Haben Sie auch kein Topheizgefühl oder kribbeln?
Topheizgefühl habe ich auch nicht.
Ich kann alles fühlen und es kribbelt nicht.
Danke.
Wie ist Geschwindigkeit beim Wasserlassen?
Oh ja, nicht mehr so schnell wie früher, aber sonst läuft es halt.
Ich habe es nicht gemessen.
Gehen Sie auch die Nacht beim Wasserlassen?
Nicht oft, ab und zu.
Aber nicht regelmäßig, nein.
Ich achte darauf, dass ich abends nicht sehr viel trinke.
Und dann klappt das.
Ich trinke gerne morgens viel und mittags viel und abends weniger.